[Musique]
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues il y a quatre ans le 13
novembre 2015 en plusieurs points de
paris à des terrasses de restaurants et
dans la salle de concert du bataclan
ainsi qu aux abords du stade de france à
saint-denis était perpétré les attaques
terroristes qui ont fait 130 morts et
350 blessés devons garder en mémoire
cette journée si douloureuse pour notre
pays et nous a renforcés dans notre
détermination à rester résolus et unis
face à la menace terroriste est à
défendre plus que jamais les valeurs de
la république que nous avons en partage
le président david assouline va nous
représenter aux cérémonies
commémoratives qui vont se dérouler
aujourd'hui à paris en ce jour
anniversaire de pensées vont même si le
temps semblait passé vers les victimes
de ces attentats leurs familles et leurs
proches en leur souvenir en leur hommage
je vous invite à observer un court
moment de recueillement
je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre chers collègues
plus d'un étudiant sur deux ne mangent
pas tous les jours à sa fin près d'un
étudiant sur deux à renoncer à se
soigner par manque d'argent il ne l'ya
que 175 mille places en résidences
étudiantes pour 700 mille étudiants
boursiers et le loyer représente plus de
70% du budget moyen des étudiants plus
d'un étudiant sur deux est obligé de
travailler pour étudier et subsister ils
occupent les emplois les plus précaires
les plus harassant et les moins
rémunérés ainsi ils composent près de 60
% de la main-d'oeuvre des plates formes
de prestations
à tout cela s'ajoutent des conditions
d'enseignement indigne et un sous
encadrement pédagogique chronique
la grande majorité de la population
estudiantine est en souffrance et
l'aggravation de sa situation
d'existence conduit à la désespérance à
des drames humains à des gestes
désespérés dont celui d'anna ce qui sont
autant de cris de détresse que vous ne
pouvez ignorer les conséquences de ce
mal-être endémiques sont catastrophiques
pour notre pays de moins en moins
d'étudiants poursuivre un cursus complet
le nombre de doctorants baisse chaque
année et la fuite des cerveaux et
maintenant manifeste à cette crise
majeure
vous répondez par une baisse de moyens
alloués à l'enseignement supérieur la
dépense par étudiant atteint aujourd'hui
son plus bas niveau depuis 2008 est
votre projet de loi de finances ne
portent pas l'ambition d' arrêter cette
chute à la jeunesse qui souhaitent
s'investir en la connaissance la culture
et les oeuvres de la pensée vous
renvoyez le message détestable qu'elle
ne serait qu'une charge qu'un fardeau
improductifs qu'il faudrait continûment
alléger merci
pour vous répondre la parole est au
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse
monsieur gabriel attal
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur ouzoulias ce vous abordez une
réalité une dure réalité qui est celle
de la précarité étudiante de la misère
étudiantes parfois réalité qui a été
remise en lumière à l'occasion de la
tragique immolation d'un jeune vendredi
à lyon et vite c'est évidemment vers lui
vers ses proches vers la communauté
étudiante et universitaires de lyon que
nos pensées se tournent aujourd'hui
frédéric vidal était présente dès samedi
dernier à lyon pour échanger avec eux
c'est une réalité c'est une réalité que
nous avons choisi de prendre à bras le
corps depuis deux ans maintenant une
réalité d'ailleurs que beaucoup des
gouvernements qui se sont succédé depuis
plusieurs années ont cherché à laquelle
ils ont cherché à répondre nous avons
ainsi supprimer la cotisation sécurité
sociale qui étaient payés par les
étudiants à chaque rentrée c'est 217
euros qui étaient payés par les
étudiants auparavant à la rentrée cette
cotisation a été supprimé nous avons
annoncé il ya deux mois maintenant une
augmentation des bourses de 46 millions
d'euros des bourses qui sont désormais
payés à date le 5 du mois et qui sont
même payé par anticipation en début
d'année pour les étudiants qui auraient
constituer leur dossier ces progrès on
ne peut pas les nier ils sont là ils
sont concrets ils sont tangibles
évidemment qu'il reste des situations
difficiles évidemment qu'il faut
poursuivre évidemment qu'il faut aussi
faire mieux connaître les dispositifs
qui existent quasiment 50 dispositif des
aides qui existent aujourd'hui à
l'université et notamment des aides pour
les situations d'urgence parce que
parfois la prime à la précarité s'ajoute
la précarité quand il ya une rupture
quand il ya un moment difficile des
aides d'urgence existent et l' enquête
qui est actuellement meunier a mené à
lyon vise à comprendre si l'université
si le crous était informé de la
situation très difficile que vivent et
ce jeune et comment expliquer qu'il
n'ait pas pu lui être proposé ces
dispositifs
il faut poursuivre c'est aussi le sens
du revenu universel d'activité de cette
concertation autour du revenu universel
d'activité qui doit nous amener à
repenser une partie de l'accompagnement
social des jeunes nous y sommes résolus
et nous allons poursuivre la parole et
votre com après collègue marie van
blonde
le groupe socialiste et républicain
avait la parole va chers collègues
merci monsieur le président je vais
poursuivre dans la même veine que mon
collègue aux liasses monsieur le
secrétaire d'état la précarité du elle
tue aussi notre projet républicain pour
la jeunesse en particulier celle qui est
issu des familles les moins aisées et
qui aspire à un progrès social par
l'éducation
l'état ne parvient pas à enrayer les
déterminismes sociaux
il s'agit de garantir à chaque étudiant
les conditions de vie nécessaires à sa
réussite
le logement l'alimentation la santé les
transports les livres qui lui sont
nécessaires
or la précarité étudiante ne cesse
d'augmenter
20% des étudiants vivent sous le seuil
de pauvreté et plus d'un tiers d'entre
eux travaillent en plus de leurs études
leur accès à la santé en pâtit on l'a
dit tout à l'heure les enquêtes
annuelles de la fage et de l'unef conclu
à une hausse du coût de la vie étudiante
de près de 3% en 2010 9 vous allez me
répondre que le montant des bourses a
été revalorisé et que vos crédits sont
en hausse pour 2020 mais cela n'est pas
suffisant lorsque dans le même temps les
frais de vie courante ne cesse de
croître que le prix du ticket de resto u
et la contribution à la vie étudiante
augmente et que vous prenez des mesures
incompréhensible comme la baisse des
appels et de l'allocation logement
social quelles mesures comptez-vous
prendre allez-vous proposer une refonte
des aides qui leur sont destinés comment
allez vous accélérer la construction des
logements étudiants dont madame la
ministre a elle-même jugée le nombre
insuffisant
nous avons besoin de réponses concrètes
pour redonner espoir à notre jeunesse
pour vous répondre
la parole est au secrétaire d'état
madame la sénatrice je veux commencer
par dire que la question de la
démocratisation de la réussite à l'école
et dans l'enseignement supérieur que
vous avez évoqué c'est ce qui guide
notre politique c'est le sens de notre
action à l'école avec le dédoublement
des classes avec l'aide aux devoirs avec
les moyens qui sont mis pour les
quartiers qui sont aujourd'hui les plus
difficiles et la démocratisation de la
réussite à l'université elle passe aussi
par la question de la condition de vie
des étudiants et c'est le sens de notre
action depuis maintenant deux ans pour
répondre à certains points que vous avez
abordé non le coût de la rentrée
universitaire n'a pas augmenté cette
année les estimations même montré qu'il
était plus faible que les années
précédentes
s'agissant du cycle est sûre le pour les
restaurants universitaires nous avons
donné une perspective à quatre ans pour
faire baisser le coût du panier de base
sur les restaurants universitaires
il y à des chantiers à continuer à
explorer à travailler c'est ce que nous
faisons avec les organisations
étudiantes encore une fois dans le cadre
de cette concertation sur le revenu
universel d'activités auxquelles
participent les organisations étudiantes
évidemment il faut continuer à avancer
avec eux sur la question du logement que
vous avez évoqué avec l'engagement du
président de la république de 60000
construction de logements pour les
étudiants
nous progressons progressivement nous
créons des logements pour les étudiants
il faut poursuivre il faut mettre tous
ces sujets sur la table
c'est la raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs
le premier ministre m'a demandé de
recevoir au plus vite les organisations
étudiantes et ce cycle de rendez vous
démarrera dès demain matin
nous travaillons main dans la main avec
eux encore une fois dans le cadre de
cette concertation et nous continuons à
avancer pour garantir que les conditions
de vie des étudiants s'améliore dans les
années qui viennent
en prenant des actions très concrètes
comme celle que nous avons engagées
depuis maintenant deux ans la blonde a
juste rappelé que la complémentaire
santé maintenant des plus obligatoire
depuis la la baisse de la sécurité
sociale étudiante et elle coûte 313
euros pour un étudiant qui veut se
prévenir s'assurer sur la complémentaire
santé avant la sécurité sociale coûté
et la parole et à notre collègue mathieu
darnaud pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
et vous me permets permettrait d'y
associer mon collègue de l'ardèche
jacques genest lundi 11 novembre à 11h52
un séisme de magnitude 5,4 a frappé le
département de l'ardèche
généralement la vallée du rhône et
nombre de communes et singulièrement la
commune du teil
nous adressons à cet instant toutes nos
pensées et notre soutien à l'ensemble
des personnes qui ont été blessées ou
qui ont connu des dégâts assez
importants
le bilan de ce séisme est aussi lourd
qu'inhabituel dans l'hexagone en effet
environ 300 bâtiments endommagés
une trentaine détruit des établissements
scolaires fermés et certains de nos
concitoyens qui sont encore aujourd'hui
hébergée dans l'urgence dans certains
gymnase de la commune à cette heure
monsieur le premier ministre les
ardéchoises et les ardéchois et j'y
associe aussi certains collègues drômois
attendent des réponses de la part de
l'état s'agissant tout d'abord des
établissements aidés centrale nucléaire
de cruas et du tricastin
l'institut de la radioprotection et de
sûreté nucléaire a indiqué ne pas avoir
constaté de dégâts visibles sur les
installations mais continue ses
investigations pouvez vous nous dire
monsieur le premier ministre si vous
avez à cette heure des informations
complémentaires
ma seconde question porte sur les
mesures d'urgence et sur la solidarité
nationale que nous appelons de nos voeux
confirmez-vous la prise
rapide d'un décret de catastrophe
naturelle et en attendant le processus
d'expertisé et d'indemnisation des
assurances quels sont les moyens
financiers d'urgence que l'on l'état
entend mettre en oeuvre pour venir en
aide aux populations touchées je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est et à monsieur willy de l'intérieur
monsieur christophe castaner vous avez
la parole monsieur plus merci monsieur
le président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur d'arnaud j'étais
hier soir à montélimar dans le hameau de
la rouvière et aussi dans la commune du
teil
ce que j'ai constaté en particulier dans
le hameau de la rouvière comme dans la
commune du teil était bien au delà des
premières indications qui était remonté
en matière de dégâts sur les logements
au moment où je vous parle je pense que
le chiffre de 800 maisons directement
impactés concernés qui font l'objet de
fissures plus ou moins importantes sur
la seule commune du teil et la réalité
que nous sommes en train de constater
dès hier nous avons procédé au
relogement dans lieu d avant-hier nous
aurons procédé au relogement dans
l'urgence de près de 300 personnes dans
trois sites différents
depuis hier nous travaillons à ce que ce
relogement soit la fois réduits dans le
volume des personnes qui doivent être
relogées par une inspection minutieuse
par les services de pompiers qui ont été
renforcés depuis ce matin par huit
équipes de la direction générale de la
gestion des crises et des catastrophes
naturelles du ministère de l'intérieur
pour qu'elle puisse réhabiliter les
logements après la levée des doutes et
pour les autres nous sommes en train de
faire en sorte qu'elle puisse dès ce
soir dormir dans des conditions plus
satisfaisantes que celles qui ont été
proposées malgré l'accueil de qualité de
très nombreux bénévoles que je veux
saluer dans des gymnases de la commune
du teil il nous faut maintenant regarder
l'avenir réparer l'urgence vous avez
évoqué les écoles publiques et privées
dans la commune du teil
vous avez évoqué les équipements publics
vous pourriez nous pourrions évoquer les
deux églises qui aujourd'hui sont aussi
menacés et l'une d'elles en bord de la
route nationale 112 avec de vrais
risques donc il nous faut nous regarde
et il nous faut
nous mobiliser regarder l'avenir
concernant l'urgence et la catastrophe
naturelle avec elisabeth bord nous avons
fait le choix de faire en sorte que la
commission puisse se réunir dès la
semaine prochaine
et concernant l'ensemble des dispositifs
d'urgence que nous allons mobiliser sous
l'autorité de la ministre en charge des
collectivités locales est en lien avec
olivier dussopt pts pour le ministère de
l'économie et finances nous de faire en
sorte de répondre présent comme l'a fait
le département dans l'immédiateté et
comme je crois le fera cet après midi le
conseil régional et le président de la
région se rendra cet après midi dans la
commune du teil je vous remercie
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
maintenant notre collègue bernard
buigues pour le groupe de la république
en marche vers la parole pour deux
minutes
merci président monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre de la transition
écologique et énergétique
ce lundi un tremblement de terre a
secoué le sud notre pays vers midi
autour de montélimar le séisme a fait
quatre blessés et a provoqué
d'importants dégâts sur la commune du
teil en ardèche maisons églises
établissements publics sont fissurés
plus de personnes 500 personnes ont été
évacuées et sont dans l'atteinte d'une
éventuelle réplique plus important
tremblement de terre enregistrés en
france depuis 16 ans avec une intensité
de 5 4 sur l'échelle de richter
cette secousse inédite pose des
questions sur la sécurité civile si
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire a précisé
qu aucun dommage n'avait été relevé sur
le site de cruas et du tricastin
le préfet de la drôme hugues moutouh a
néanmoins annoncé l'arrêt des réacteurs
de la centrale de cruas dans la soirée
de lundi
hier un séisme de magnitude de 3,1 sur
l'échelle de richter a également été
enregistrée à strasbourg et des f a fait
savoir que la secousse n'avait pas été
ressentie sur la centrale de fessenheim
si la france compte 58 réacteurs
nucléaires en activité répartis sur 19
sites
cinq sites sont situés sur des zones
sismiques dont quatre dans la vallée du
rhône
madame la ministre dans ce contexte
pouvez vous rassurer nos concitoyens sur
le niveau de protection des centrales
nucléaires
face à de tels risques sismiques pour
vous répondre la parole de calvinistes
la transition écologique et solidaire
mais d'abord vous avez la parole
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur bruit comme l'a souligné
christophe castaner le gouvernement
apporte tout son soutien à nos
concitoyens victimes d'un tremblement de
terre qui a touché l'ardèche et au delà
la vallée du rhône lundi dernier et je
voudrais à mon tour salué l'intervention
des forces de secours et des services de
l'état pour venir en aide aux sinistrés
alors concernant les installations
nucléaires la vigilance est bien sûr
total toutes les procédures de suivi et
de contrôle ont été mises en oeuvre dès
la survenue du séisme
c'est l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
autorité indépendante qui supervise les
contrôles qui sont mis en oeuvre par les
opérateurs est là et ça n'a pu nous
confirmer qu aucun dommage n'a été
constaté sur les centrale de cruas et de
tricastin et c'est donc en application
du principe de précaution qu' edf a
arrêté les trois réacteurs qui sont qui
étaient en activité sur le site de cruas
des vibrations ayant été ressenties sur
le site de cruas aucune eau qu aucun à
aucune mesure n'a été effectuée par
contre sur la centrale de tricastin et
c'est bien la sn qui déterminera les
conditions de remise en service de ces
réacteurs probablement en fin de semaine
je vous précise
s'agissant de fessenheim
qu'effectivement aucune secousse n'a été
ressentie sur le site de fessenheim
de façon générale le risque sismique est
naturellement pris en compte dans la
conception des centrales nucléaires en
fonction de l'historique des séismes
observés dans la région et depuis
l'accident de fukushima l'asn a demandé
aux exploitants de procéder à des
évaluations de sûreté complémentaires
ces dispositions sont mises en oeuvre en
trois phases la première à d'ores et
déjà été mises en oeuvre
la seconde le sera d'ici la fin de
l'année 2021 et la troisième sera mise
en oeuvre en fonction des visites
périodiques qui sont réalisés sur les
centrales la parole aux acteurs notre
collègue françoise laborde
pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen vous
avez la parole sur koné merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur la france peut
s'enorgueillir d'avoir fait des lumières
la source son pacte républicain contre
tous les obscurantismes et les
fanatismes
c'est l'honneur de notre république de
rassembler nos concitoyens dans ce
qu'ils ont de commun
par delà leurs origines et leurs
croyances pour la très grande majorité
d'entre nous ici je ne peux hélas pas
dire tous cette conception civique de la
nation repose sur la laïcité
une laïcité à laquelle on ne peut
accoler aucun adjectif une laïcité
fandor la concorde de la société en
dépassant les identités particulières
qui ne résume pas à un individu une
laïcité facilitant l'édification d'un
monde commun aux hommes
sur la base de leur égalité et de leur
liberté de conscience assurée par la
mise à distance de tous les groupes de
pression comme l'écrit henri pena ruiz
la manifestation du 10 novembre a
malheureusement montré que la voie de
l'apaisement et est encore longue
nous y avons entendu ceux qui prônent la
division le clivage de la société le
repli sur des identités a signé comme si
le déterminisme social était une
fatalité
nous y avons lu des slogans qualifiant
de liberticide les lois de la république
et nous y avons vu les symboles d'une
époque tragique de notre histoire
détourner d'une façon indigne
provocatrice mais assumé faisant écho
aux insultes publiques à l'encontre de
certains sénateurs qualifiés de nazis il
ya quelques jours
or mes chers collègues les symboles ont
un sens que nous n'oublions pas et leur
instrumentalisation par certains nourrit
les amalgames monsieur le ministre mon
groupe porte la laïcité avec force et
conviction au nom de l'universalisme et
de légal respect dû aux croyants comme
aux non croyants
la laïcité ce n'est pas simplement
permettra dès qu elle communauté de
cohabiter en se tolérant
non c'est bien plus que cela elle est la
condition de la fraternité républicaine
en ce triste jour anniversaire des
attentats du 13 novembre 2015 alors que
les crispations identitaires progressent
il est urgent pour rassembler et apaisée
d'agir
dans ces conditions comment votre
gouvernement compte-t-il défendre notre
laïcité
je vous remercie merci
pour vous répondre
la parole
et à monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice faveur d' je connais votre
combat je connais votre implication
je sais aussi que c'est ce combat et
cette implication qui marque votre
groupe
mais je sais aussi combien le sénat est
attaché à cette valeur fondatrice est
fondamental qu'est la laïcité
vous l'avez dit dimanche une
manifestation est organisée par ceux qui
prétendent lutter contre je cite
l'islamophobie
évidemment je respecte nous respectons
ce droit fondamental de manifester mais
notre ligne est claire
manifester c'est un droit qui doit
respecter toutes les valeurs de la
république et celle de la laïcité fait
partie de ces valeurs de la république
nous devons évidemment grâce à la
laïcité protège et le choix religieux de
chacune et de chacun mais ne jamais
accepter de mélanger religion et
radicalité ne jamais accepter de
mélanger l'islam dans ce qu'ils portent
de fait religieux dans la culture qu'il
représente et l'islamisme comme une
organisation politique qui veut son
construire contre les valeurs de la
république contre ce que nous sommes
contre nos identités contre ses
principes fondamentaux tels que
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
le fait que certains manifestants soient
venus dimanche avec justement des
revendications qui vont contre ces
valeurs qui doit faire notre commun
notre vivre ensemble et donc la défense
de nos valeurs est totalement scandaleux
le fait que ce soit construit sur un
appel un appel qui dénonce pêle-mêle des
lois liberticides le silence complice
des institutions étatiques chargées de
lutter contre le racisme les délations
abusive jusqu'au plus haut niveau de
l'état contre des musulmans dont le seul
tort serait l'appartenance réelle ou
supposée à une religion ou encore les
dispositifs de surveillance de masse qui
conduisent à une criminalisation pure et
simple de la pratique religieuse se
rendent au fond complice des menaces qui
pèsent sur la république et nous serons
madame la sénatrice totalement engagée à
vos côtés aux côtés des sénateurs pour
faire en sorte que cette laïcité qui
n'est pas à ni provocatrice ni au fond
rejeté ne soit pas non plus naïveté et
nous devons au contraire faire en sorte
que pour chaque valeur qui serait mise
en cause par ceux qui aujourd'hui on
religion considère qu'il y aura un
intérêt supérieur à ce qui nous
rassemble nous puissions tous ensemble
qu'on battre pied à pied pour que la
république soit partout chez elle
merci monsieur mener la parole et vatan
madame claudine kaufmann pour le
sénateur n'appartenant à aucun groupe
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame le ministre des
solidarités et de la santé au delà des
clivages politiques partisans
nous nous accordons tous sur le droit
pour nos compatriotes a bénéficié d'un
régime de retraite juste et équitable
offrant à chacun la perspective d'une
vie digne
au terme de nombreuses années de labeur
si le candidat macron s'était engagé à
réformer les régimes de retraite tout en
préservant le futur niveau de vie des
personnes concernées
force est de constater que le président
qu'il est devenu a promptement oublier
cette promesse en effet sous couvert
d'une prétendue équité vous proposez que
désormais chaque euro cotisé offre les
mêmes droits et que toute période
travaillait même minime soit prise en
compte la réforme que vous défendez si
elle était adopté ferait ainsi
abstraction pour le calcul des pensions
des 25 meilleures années pour le privé
et des six derniers mois pour le public
il ne s'agit là que d'un nivellement par
le bas dont l'unique dessein est de
réduire drastiquement le niveau de
toutes les pensions vous feignez
d'ignorer en effet que tout au long
d'une vie professionnelle de plus de
quatre décennies s'enchaînent les
faibles mines rémunération les périodes
favorables les emplois précaires et
parfois aussi le chômage votre réforme
naboo dire la beauty rac à précariser
davantage les français les plus modestes
qui parvenu au soir de leur vie subiront
encore les affres de la pauvreté
de surcroît votre projet de réforme fait
totalement abstraction de la pénibilité
de certains emplois
en effet les salariés concernés ne
bénéficieront d'aucune compensation
votre vision de l'équité pour le moins
singulière
cette réforme des retraites méprisant la
justice sociale porte toujours en elle
une inconnue la valeur du point
comment et sur quelle base allez vous
déterminez cette dernière et commencera
telles garanties contre toute baisse je
vous remercie pour vos réponses la
parole est aux prémices et en retraite
délégué auprès de la ministre des
solidarités de la santé monsieur de le
voir dans la parole monsieur le
président madame la sénatrice
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs vous
avez raison de vous adresser à la
ministre des solidarités car sous son
autorité le président la république ait
voulu que le projet de réforme des
retraites soit sue le site de la
solidarité
je vous remercie d'apporter votre
soutien
un régime équitable avec les mêmes
règles pour tous et qui a pour but de
corriger les inégalités du système
actuel sous l'autorité du premier
ministre nous proposons de faire en
sorte que dans un système de
redistribution validé par le conseil
d'orientation des retraites qui fait que
le passage des 25 années à la totalité
de la carrière fait une redistribution
au profit des retraites des 40 % des
retraités les plus faibles c'est-à-dire
celles et ceux qui sont en dessous de
1200 à 1300 euros
nous avons aussi intégré la volonté les
françaises et des français de réduire
l'écart des pensions entre les hommes et
les femmes au profit des femmes qui est
actuellement de 40 % les propositions
que nous formulons fait que nous allons
réduire de 10 à 20 % c'est-à-dire la
moitié 7 et cadres nous avons aussi reçu
le soutien de nos concitoyens pour faire
en sorte que dès le premier enfant dès
le premier enfant
il y est une majoration de la pension
qui fait que le nombre de femmes qui
vont bénéficier de cela va passer de 3
millions à 8 millions
nous avons aussi fait en sorte que le
système qui accompagne par point les
interruptions d'activité les parcours
précaire ce que vous évoquez sont plus
favorables et que nous allons dans le
coefficient dans le rapport que j'ai
remis au président et au premier
ministre
il y à une réduction du coefficient gini
c'est à dire l'écart de pauvreté et vous
voyez bien que notre préoccupation
y compris pour la fonction publique y
compris pour la référence des six
derniers mois qui a été mise en place
alors qu'il n'y avait pas de prime
nous voulons faire un système plus juste
plus équitable plus transparent qui
correspond à une nécessité de renforcer
la cohésion de la nation coupures ne fut
[Musique]